bonsoir bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct je suis ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir quelle réforme de
l'école emmanuel macron et le nouveau
ministre de l'éducation pap ndiaye était
à marseille aujourd'hui le président
souhaite généraliser ce qu'il appelle
l'école du futur expérimenté aujourd'hui
dans une soixantaine d'établissements
dac cité phocéenne alors qu'est ce que
ça veut dire très concrètement on en
parle dans un instant dans notre grand
débat avec nos invités soixante dix ans
sur le trône longévité jamais vu dans
l'histoire la reine elizabeth au sommet
de sa popularité pour son jubilé de
platine les images de la famille royale
au balcon de buckingham ont fait le tour
du monde on va revenir évidemment sur
cette journée de ferveur outre-manche
qui fait parfois quelques envieux même
si l'on est amoureux de la république
grand témoin ce soir fait m'accroche
grands experts de la monarchie anglaise
enfin nous trouvons nos a franchi pour
leur parti pris ce soir dans le carnet
de campagne dès l'amont d'un gab à
quelles sont les chances de la droite
aux législatives le regard de la
sémiologue mariette darrigrand sur les
origines du mot députés et puis le coup
de gueule de manuel du cros sur ce
mouvement très en vogue de retour à la
terre voilà pour le menu c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs égalité des chances ou
école à deux vitesses qui a compris quoi
on va s'arrêter ce soir sur le projet de
réforme des manuels maquereau en matière
d'éducation c'était l'objet de son
déplacement à marseille aujourd'hui aux
côtés du ministre pape ndiaye vous le
voyez sur ces images bonsoir anne
christine langues et bienvenue à vous
beaucoup de questions à vous poser ce
soir pour mieux cerner ce que veut faire
précisément le chef de l'état vous êtes
député la république en marche de paris
vii candidate à votre réélection aux
législatives ancien prof d'anglais je
dis pas de bêtises vous avez enseigné
dans le secondaire pendant des années
c'était dans un établissement parisien
bonsoir philippe gatreau l'eau sont
bienvenues sur ce plateau professeur
agrégé de sciences économiques et
sociales dans l'essonne vous est
également chroniqueur pour le magazine
alternatives économiques sur les sujets
liés à l'éducation bon match à lens puis
aussi et formateur à l'insp et l'aspect
vous vous expliquer en donnant du
national du professeur d'éducation très
bien ses 10 ans
bonsoir laurent avec offs qui ont soir
et bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes
vice président national de la pep la
peine quand on est parent d'élève on
connaît fédération des parents d'élèves
de l'enseignement public un syndicat de
parents d'élèves coloré une feuille d
une fédération mais coloré politiquement
nike est apolitique et arnaud delpech va
nous rejoindre dans un tout petit
instant et les professeurs de
mathématiques au collège et secrétaire
du snes dans le val-de-marne les
mathématiques c'est très important parce
qu'ils vont faire leur retour en option
dès la première et dès la rentrée
prochaine on va en parler mais d'abord
pour nous planter le décor de ces
annonces marseillaise de ces annonces
présidentielles j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir clément méric bonjour il va
remplacer pour quelques jours l'ami
stéphane blakowski qui va nous revenir
pas d'inquiétude si j'ai bien compris
votre billet tout de suite
[Musique]
si j'ai bien compris ce soir clément
hélas si j'ai bien compris myriam
emmanuel macron n'a pas forcément pour
ambition de dégraisser le mammouth mais
il voudrait bien le rendre un peu plus
agile et plus innovants et pour cela il
a un projet l'école du futur il l'a
lancée il ya neuf mois de cela à
marseille et il était de retour
aujourd'hui dans la cité phocéenne pour
enclencher l'étape d'après et notre
ambition avec monsieur le ministre c'est
ensuite dans les prochains mois de
pouvoir généraliser cette approche est
ce dire partout sur le territoire on
veut définir en quelque sorte des grands
objectifs et aux fonds donnés tout à la
fois plus de moyens mais nous plus de
liberté aussi pédagogique aux
enseignants en lien avec les parents
d'élèves avec le périscolaire avec les
élus pour au fond rétablir cette égalité
des chances qui est la promesse
républicaine alors plus de liberté
donnée aux enseignants ça va se traduire
comment concrètement ya cinq ans
emmanuel macron le start peur vous
aurais répondu on va faire du bottom up
myriam sauf que la start up nation c'est
un peu du passé désormais on dit qu'on
va faire confiance au terrain
concrètement ça veut dire quoi eh bien
ça veut dire que ce sont les directeurs
d'école et les enseignants qui vont
proposer eux-mêmes des projets
pédagogiques innovants donc ça c'est pas
trés jupitérien est justement au miriam
souvenez vous du discours prononcé par
emmanuel macron le soir de sa réélection
cette ère nouvelle ne sera pas la
continuité du quinquennat qui s'achève
mais l'invention collective d'une
méthode refonder pour cinq années de
mieux au service de notre pays vous
l'avez compris myriam la fameuse
nouvelle méthode promise par emmanuel
macron et bien elle est là dans ce
projet d'école du futur alors donner
plus de moyens innover plus de liberté
de la confiance aux enseignants ça
devrait plaire ça aux syndicats c'est là
où les choses se compliquent un peu sur
le papier je suis d'accord avec vous
l'école du futur a de quoi plaire aux
enseignants d'autant qu emmanuel macron
s'est engagé à ce que ceux qui jouent je
sois mieux payés ce qui coince myriam en
fait c'est cette petite phrase qu'il a
prononcée il ya neuf mois à marseille on
la réécoute
faut que ces directeurs d'école ils
puissent choisir l'équipe pédagogique
jeudi plein de gros mots pour beaucoup
de gens là j'en ai conscience
mais je dis ce que j'ai entendu parce
que les parents me disent à tel endroit
les profs viennent plus et c'est ça
arrive parce qu'à des gens qui sont
fatigués travailler trop longtemps dans
des quartiers difficiles et ça n'a pas
loupé les syndicats ont vu rouge tout de
suite pourquoi et bien parce que laisser
les directeurs d'école recruter leurs
équipes cela revient en quelque sorte un
mettre en concurrence les enseignants
entre eux et potentiellement et bien
c'est tout le système actuel de mutation
des enseignants qui pourraient
disparaître alors anne christine lins
fait non de la tête vous allez réagir
mais il faut quand même préciser que le
président a voulu être rassurant
aujourd'hui à marseille sur ce point des
lieux effectivement il a d'abord dit que
il y aura toujours des règles nationales
pour ce sujet sensible chez les
enseignants et il a précisé que les
directeurs d'école ne ferait pas leur
propre mercato c'est l'expression qui
l'a employé ils auront en revanche une
forme de droit de regard en quelque
sorte pour s'assurer que les enseignants
qui veulent enseigner dans leur école et
bien partage bien le projet pédagogique
qui a été mise en place alors est ce
qu'il ya un risque d' école à deux
vitesses dans ces conditions craignent
effectivement certains syndicats pour
eux il y aura d'un côté les écoles qui
attireront les meilleurs profs parce
qu'elles auront les projets pédagogiques
les plus séduisants et puis il y aura de
l'autre ces écoles où ni les enseignants
ni les élèves n'auront vraiment envie
d'aller bon c'est pas franchement un
cadeau pour le nom réunissent de
l'éducation quand même à faire passer et
papa ndiaye c'est très fort on peut voir
les choses sous cet angle et puis on
peut se dire aussi que c'est justement
pour mener à bien cette réforme qu'il a
été nommé à ce poste de ministre de
l'éducation nationale parce que pap
ndiaye c'est un peu l'anti blanc caire
en quelque sorte il est là pour déminer
le terrain arrondir les angles là où
jean michel blanquer avait tendance à
crisper le corps enseignant est
d'ailleurs emmanuel macron n'a pas
manqué aujourd'hui de saluer son nouveau
ministre il l'a fait en ces termes il a
montré par ses études et son parcours
académique son souci de l'égalité des
chances tenir la promesse de l'égalité
des chances c'est justement le la boucle
est bouclée merci infiniment pour ce
papier si j'ai bien compris
personnellement j'ai bien compris on va
vérifier ça avec vous j'ai vu vos
sourcils se lever anne-christine glande
toujours école à deux vitesses c'est
vraiment ce qu'on entend en permanence
sur sept au fond liberté pédagogique
mais surtout liberté dans le recrutement
qui serait donnée aux chefs
d'établissement est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire précisément ce que veut faire
le chef de l'état pour rassurer les
enseignants les syndicats qui craignent
une forme de privatisation tout
simplement hou hou de mise en
concurrence des établissements et des
enseignants
non je pense qu'effectivement le maître
mot c'est davantage de liberté davantage
de souplesse et davantage de confiance
aux équipes pédagogiques ça c'est je
pense l'idée générale après la situation
quelle est l on a effectivement un gros
problème de recrutement une profession
qui est très peu attractif donc il ya
évidemment la question de la
rémunération qui va en parler attendait
qui est importante et qui permettra d'
assez la priorité pour galérer c'est ça
je n'y aurais rémunérées
non non non ce sont des choses qui sont
qui sont
importantes oui toutes les deux sèvres
il ya effectivement la question de la
rémunération
et puis après il ya aussi la
satisfaction qu'on peut avoir dans son
métier il ya aussi susciter de
l'enthousiasmé il ya aussi entendre les
équipes pédagogiques qui souvent ont
envie de faire des choses de mai quand
la
pédagogie moi j'ai mené j'aimerais
animer un grand débat hier dans ma
circonscription pendant trois heures
avec des enseignants des parents des
animateurs etc et j'ai entendu
énormément de gens qui nous disaient
nous on a envie de faire telle et telle
chose tel et tel projet et on est
même à dire par une hiérarchie qui en
fait est toof un petit peu
dur et les les attributs militaires il
ya une vision encore dans l'éducation
nationale qui est très monolithique
c'est à dire en fait il ya tout le monde
qui est au pas quelle que soit la région
que dans laquelle vous habitez pour un
recruteur on peut être plus + montre
actuelle d'autres pas forcément des
enseignants fondé il ya deux choses il
ya deux choses il ya d'abord la question
de la liberté et de pouvoir laisser les
enseignants faire ce qu'ils aiment créer
avoir des idées avoir des des projets et
et être créatif il a ça me semble
extrêmement important la deuxième partie
c'est la question du recrutement qui
fait grand bruit mais à ce stade le chef
de l'état a dit que s'est fondé sur
l'expérience marque marseillaise 59
écoles de mémoire qui sont dans les
quartiers très bien très très
déshéritées du nord de marseille et où
on se rend compte que malgré les efforts
qui ont été faits malgré les
dédoublements malgré des crédits de la
politique de la ville on a encore des
enfants qui dans ce système ont du mal à
réussir et donc ils voudraient essayer
dans ces quartiers
prioritairement simplement à marseille
avoir attiré à elle attiré les
enseignantes pas forcément on appelle
des postes à profil c'est à dire des
gens qui viennent sur un projet
spécifique travailler en équipe dans des
conditions un peu différente en termes
d'horaires en termes de projets
pédagogiques ils sont motivés ils ont
très envie d'y aller ils sont unis sont
soudés c'est une équipe ils ont des
fonds des choses innovantes et ça se
fait déjà ça se fait déjà beaucoup dans
l'éducation nationale notamment dans
toutes les structures de lutte contre le
décrochage à l'ère où vous avez
effectivement des équipes qui sont
recrutés sur profil vous a laissé le
temps voilà d'exposer au fond le projet
du président de la république philippe
battre lors assurée par assuré sur sur
cette espèce de liberté pédagogique
c'est le projet qui viendrait au fond
définir la politique d'un établissement
davantage que un carcan
égalitaire pour tous les pour tout
laisser pour tout le système je sais pas
si le carcan et égalitaire sont des mots
qui vont ensemble mais je voudrais dire
rapidement trois choses d'avoir un petit
point d'histoire mais je vais commencer
à enseigner en 80
81 et donc d dès cette époque je me
souviens que
gabriel cohn bendit aller voir françois
mitterrand puis alain savary pour créer
le lycée de saint nazaire et ensuite il
ya eu d'autres
et qui est décédé il ya quelques
quelques temps là et donc ces
établissements innovants
il existe depuis très longtemps ils ont
été bien malmené au cours de ces
dernières années et notamment par pas
mal de rigidité il ya aussi les micro
lycée et c est à ce moment là les postes
à profil ça existe en effet un mais moi
j'ai le souvenir il appelait pas cette
approche des choses mais pas unique je
peux terminer mais je préfère
donc les postes à profit c'est tout
simplement dès que l'on demande aux
enseignants s'ils sont d'accord avec le
projet la deuxième chose que je voudrais
dire c'est que dans le discours de
monsieur macron qui qui est très présent
sur ce sujet et à tel point que que
monsieur le dialogue semble très effacé
sur ce plan c'est qu'on parle du chef
d'établissement moi je me réjouis
d'avoir entendu dans la parole de l'un
christine langue qu'on parle plutôt des
collectifs mois pour moi le d'innovation
elle ne peut être que si elle émane d'un
c'est l'équipe pédagogique d'insolence
des types pédagogique
de bordeaux c'est bien alors même s'il y
en a un qui a la fonction de
deux principales c'est bien une équipe
qui qui crée le projet enfin la
troisième chose que je voudrais dire et
très rapidement c'est que évidemment on
peut se dire que c'est très intéressant
que il faut développer l'innovation j'ai
moi même été président du conseil
national de l'innovation entre temps de
la culture des
ces propositions certaines ont les
formules est déjà à cette époque dans un
rapport dont je ne sais où ils se
trouvent dans
la démarche non mais par contre le
timing est quand même très particulier
parce que on est face à une profession
qui est extrêmement malmené qui est en
souffrance qui est crispé et on leur
sort un discours quasi managériale où il
y à une injonction à l'innovation et il
faut pas s'étonner que finalement ça à
l'effet inverse de celui qui est
souhaitée c'est à dire finalement
rebuter les enseignants par rapport à
une idée moi celle de l'innovation
pédagogique je la soutiens je la défends
depuis très longtemps
et je crois que c'est quand même un gros
effet pervers voilà en gros pourquoi pas
mais c'est pas le moment si je comprends
bien je voudrais connaître jean savon
voilà on va en parler d urgence la
rémunération la pénurie de recrutement
pour la rentrée prochaine dans un
instant mais sur cette école du futur
candy les parents d'élèves qu'on
distille vous avez commencé à l'absence
d'appel à regarder de près ce que ça
pourrait recouvrir comme réalité pour
pour nos enfants pour les élèves tout à
fait état son suisse a depuis déjà les
premières annonces ya neuf mois là haut
on est aussi content d'entendre que le
président a décidé de se soucier plus en
amont et mieux les parents d'élèves il
l'a dit donc on attend de voir c'est une
première chose est de jeunes chose
effectivement les directeurs d'école ne
sont pas des chefs d'établissement
encore malgré la loi riac qu'il aura
donné
d'avancé non encore loin ouais donc ça
fait trop technique pour rider l'idée
qu'on puise peut-être dans des
établissements dits en difficulté
ouvrir à d'autres profils qu'ils ne
soient pas forcément des enseignants
fonctionnaires qui ont passé des des
concours laisser plus de liberté dans le
recrutement même si on comprend que
voilà il y aura un droit de regard mais
c'est pas forcément le chef
d'établissement qui le fera ça va dans
le bon sens pour les grandes stations
c'est déjà le cas aujourd'hui puisque on
recrute massivement des contractuels
après associé directeur d'école à notre
sens ça passe aussi par lui donner la
responsabilité qui va avec ce qu'ils
font il faut trouver une cohérence quand
même donc nous parents on l'a on à
réagir là-dessus le moment cette
fiabilité non en tant que parent notre
premier contact c'est le directeur
d'école lorsque les parents découvrent
que le dicta directeur d'école né
directeur que par le titre mais
non il n'est pas chef d'établissement et
je veux dire il est pris en étau entre
l'inspecteur de circonscription et les
autres enseignes aussi la municipalité
donc quelque part
il n'est qu'un collègue des charges et
des autres des autres et c'est
finalement pour nous parents on y enlève
des statuts donc c'est un train de la
courbe bon alors ça c'est encore un
autre débat mais là là mais il est
dans les gorges du projet de loi d une
bonne chose qui puisse être impliqué
c'est tout à fait et en jour d'hui en
nous toutes les mesures qui vont pour
trouver des solutions aux problèmes de
recrutement qu'on a aujourd'hui qui est
un véritable problème dire c'est une
bonne chose après il faudra être
peut-être pas commencé à mettre la
charrue avant les boeufs alors arnaud
delpech bonsoir merci d'avoir patienté
avant de prendre la parole rappelle que
vous êtes professeur de mathématiques
c'est hyper important des mathématiques
parce qu'on cherche des profs en ce
moment on va en parler vous êtes dans un
collège à créteil et vous vous êtes
membre du snes fsu
94 école à deux vitesses on entend déjà
les syndicats a expliqué qu on va au
fond remettre en cause l'égalité
tout simplement dans dans le statut de
l'école républicaine
est ce que vous voyez les choses comme
ça oui tout à fait moi je pense que la
question aujourd'hui de l'éducation
nationale s'est pas c'est pas de savoir
si si on va avoir plus de liberté
pédagogique ce qui me fait beaucoup rire
d'ailleurs puisque en fait sur les
questions des programmes les syndicats
et la profession ne sont jamais
consultés donc ça me fait beaucoup rire
qu'on nous parle de liberté pédagogique
dont l'occident ne nous consulte pas ce
qu'il ya c'est que déjà il ya une crise
une crise du recrutement absolument sans
précédent alors je m'excuse m'a nommé la
satisfaction du métier bien bien fait je
vous rappellerai qu'il ne nourrit pas
qu'elle ne remplit pas le frigo qui ne
payent pas de loyer donc il va falloir
un peu plus que ça pour attirer des
jeune professeur on va parler justement
de la rémunération parce que pour
l'instant ce qu'on sait c'est qu'il va y
avoir quand même un volet rémunération
augmentation globale des gel du point
d'indicé qui a été décidé mais sur la
démarche c'est à dire en gros plus
d'autonomie dans le recrutement plus de
liberté pédagogique dans l'enseignement
mais aussi plus de nouvelles missions
donc peut-être plus de rémunérations il
ya un côté donnant donnant dans tout ça
oui c'est un peu comme c'est un peu
comme l'augmentation du cours d'achat
qui nous a été donnée par blanc caire
selon lui lorsque le dans un de ses
premiers décrets il a imposé une
deuxième heure supplémentaire aux
enseignants aux enseignantes donc ces
salles augmentation pourra d'achat en
fait c'est travailler plus donc à aucune
augmentation puis je rappelle au passage
que les heures supplémentaires dans
l'enseignement ils sont moins payés que
les autres postes ça se généralise et
l'école du futur pour vous c'est non le
problème c'est que là aujourd'hui on
nous présente une école du futur qui a
beaucoup de préceptes
prix et aux années 80 et aux années
thatcher donc je vois pas trop ce
qu'elle a dû futur
sur sur les chefs d'établissement qui
pourrait recruter les enseignants je
vois pas ce que ça va ce que ça va
changer si ce n'est brisé encore plus un
statut qui attaqué de toutes parts
détruire légalité des collègues face à
la mutation qui aujourd'hui nationale la
rupture de l'égalité républicaine de
l'école française ça c'est ce qui
revient très souvent ri pourquoi voilà
tout à fait vous allez répondre et en
fait ce que ça va conduire ça va
conduire à des déserts éducatif comme
aujourd'hui à des déserts médicaux
médicaux donc les super prof comme quand
il a été présenté par un madame vont
aller dans les bonnes écoles et les
quartiers défavorisés comme d'habitude
seront laissés à l'abandon de mise en
concurrence
avec ce système de recrutement plus
libre alors qu'est ce que vous répondez
sur le fond ben je compte je réponds que
je ne comprends pas ce débat c'est à
dire qu'en fait on peut être extrêmement
innovant dans des quartiers qui sont
très en difficulté et d'ailleurs c'est
là qu'il faut l'être donc je ce débat
sur l'école à deux vitesses jeu là je ne
la comprends pas très bien dans la
mesure où il s'agit pas comme l'a dit le
président de la république de faire un
grand mercato où tout le monde vous tout
le monde se serre et cetera tout ça sera
quand même très organisé mais la
possibilité pendant les mutations des
enseignants aujourd'hui c'est ça qu'elle
craigne oui mais est-ce que ce que ce
que je disais tout à l'heure c'est que
effectivement il ya un certain nombre
d'endroits et on parlait de marseille
tout à l'heure où peut-être il faut
effectivement essayé d'être plus de
laisser plus de liberté aux équipes de
susciter davantage de motivation parce
que vous savez quand vous allez dans des
quartiers qui sont extrêmement difficile
en général le métier difficile dans ces
quartiers là et les gens n'y vont pas
toujours de bon coeur les enseignants
quand avec une mutation nationale n'y
vont pas toujours de bon coeur parce que
c'est objectivement difficile
aujourd'hui les mieux rémunérés 1 quand
mais quand il a trouvé juste mais quand
ils sont quand il ya un projet
pédagogique un projet d' équipe et
qu'ils choisissent d'y aller et qu'ils
ont qu'ils adhèrent à notre projet parce
qu'il pense que ça va rentrer
véritablement faire progresser les
élèves et qui sont 10 20 à se lancer
dans ce projet est encore une fois à une
échelle à une assez petite échelle ça
peut susciter de l'enthousiasmé des
vocations et remédier à la relance avant
de penser l'école du futur il faut
penser pnsr l'école d'aujourd'hui alors
regardez ça la priorité mais n'est
ration on vous a préparé un
joli effectivement dans ce livre
et ça fait effectivement beaucoup de
temps que les enseignants sont
déconsidérés alors rien leurs salaires
sont très faibles
le
l'idée de
rémunérer pu mieux
façade avec des contreparties
c'est une idée qu'il faut que les vannes
complètement abonde d'art donnez moi de
vous investir et quand même qu'on
regarde parce que c'est très concret
bien chambre le salaire moyen d'un
enseignant ses 2400 90 euros mensuels
quand on est professeur des écoles c'est
2407 quand on est professeur agrégé
3719 je parle de temps complet bien sûr
et quand on est contractuel 2000 euros
et des poussières c'est évidemment peu
c'est moins c'est 20 % de moins que la
moyenne des pays de céder qu'est ce
qu'on vous a promis une augmentation
globale ça c'est dans les tuyaux à ce
qu'on peut le dire aujourd'hui est le
dégel du point d'indicé est ce que le
président va sans rentrer dans le
donnant donnant ça c'est un autre sujet
mais déjà augmenté de façon globale les
enseignants dans notre pays bien sûr les
deux combien ça les prévisions de la tva
les enseignants ont été déjà augmentés
dans le précédent quinquennat trop peu
quelques on l'avait on avait
effectivement
ça c'est là où verser magique un le
gouvernement avait efforts effectivement
décidé de d'augmenter les débuts de
carrière jusque pendant les premières
années parce que c'est là qu'on est très
en dessous des pays de l' ocde après
plus vous progressez dans votre carrière
plus vous rejoignez la pl la moyenne des
pays de l'osce et 2 en fin de carrière
on la retraite est supérieur en france
que dans les autres pays de l' ocde mais
là où on était vraiment très en dessous
c'était en début de carrière donc on a
fait le choix effectivement d'ogone
allez vous les avez senti ces
rémunérations du tout aujourd'hui parce
qu'aujourd'hui
beaucoup
attendent attendait c'est faux c'est à
dire que les enseignants en début de
carrière n'ont pas gardé gagné 52 près
30% des enseignants qui ont été
documentés c'est exactement ce set
exactement note c'est exactement ce que
j'ai dit puisqu'on a fait le choix pour
des brûlures pendant le prêt le
précédent cas les deux mais ce sont les
met plutôt l'accent celui de l'arrière
pour rattraper échelons s'il avait la
place je réponds à votre question c'est
qu'effectivement dans ce quinquennat il
y aura bien sûr et le président
enveloppe quinquennat le nouveau
quinquennat le président de la
république s'y est engagé il y aura une
rémunération inconditionnels un
conditionne de l'ensemble de la dudh et
gel du point d'indicé alors sa hausse
est liée au dés l
contacts d'affaires
déjà lauréat colas a fait partir des
discussions qui auront lieu avec les
organisations syndicales mais je crois
que le président a eu l'occasion de dire
que l'objectif à la fin du quinquennat
c'est qu'un enseignant aucun enseignant
ne commence à moins de 2000 euros de
dettes on m'a écouté ces 10,1 on verra
on verra pas ce que tous ces projets de
loi aujourd'hui on est quand même une
virgule et une fois le smic pour des
collègues qui commence je rappelle quand
même qui sont éligibles d'actu et
d'activités pardon
ça doit faire l'objet de toutes
été augmenté ces dix seuls c'est la
seule valorisation salariale l'urgence
est l on a parlé des rémunérations je
pense que tout le monde est d'accord il
faut mieux payer les profs dans notre
pays et ça c'est un constat qui est fait
par les parents d'élèves aussi c'est un
constat qui est fait quels que soient
les partis politiques on l'a vu dans la
campagne présidentielle mais l'urgence
est aussi de savoir s'il y aura assez
d'enseignants à la rentrée prochaine en
septembre la plus grosse académies de
france l'académie de versailles manque
cruellement de prof depuis lundi vous
avez sûrement entendu parler de ça elles
recrutent en organisant un vaste job
dating 30 minutes d'entretien pour
convaincre ou pour séduire et c'est une
forme d'appel au secours aussi pour
venir peupler les classes reportage
marion becker avec antoine diaz et betty
ils espèrent tous devenir professeur et
changer de vie professionnelle
j'ai eu l'occasion de d'effectuer un
bilan de compétences avant de partir en
congé maternité et de signer une rupture
conventionnelle est donc 7
ce bilan de compétences a amené
justement à l'eau métier de professeur
des écoles a pris
plus tôt pour être professeur d'histoire
géo alors j'ai postulé pour la prof un
poste par bonds de professeurs d eps au
collège lycée et mon parcours chez
actuellement éducateur dans une ville et
un club de foot génisson stop pour la
plupart d'entre eux c'est une
reconversion professionnelle elle
l'académie de versailles espère ainsi
recruté plus de 1000 contractuelle car
le concours d'enseignant peine à attirer
cette année sur mille quatre cent trente
postes ouverts en primaire seul 484
candidats sont admissibles au collège
aussi certaines spécialités comme les
mathématiques l'allemand ou les lettres
classiques manque d'enseignants leur jeu
c'est de faire en sorte que nous ayons
les professeurs qui pour la rentrée et
comme à l'habitude nous fournissons nos
besoins par le concours qui reste une
voie d'accès majoritaire dans
l'éducation nationale est également
d'assurer et bien elle a vu là nous de
personnel sous statut du contrat pour
postuler les candidats doivent d'abord
remplir quelques critères un bac + 3
pour enseigner en primaire un bac + 4
pour le second degré ils ont trente
minutes chrono pour convaincre le jury
composé de deux inspecteurs de
l'éducation nationale qu'ils sont faits
pour enseigner la motivation c'est
vraiment pour nous c'est la priorité
absolue parce que quelqu'un de motivé on
voit bien dans les candidates que j'ai
eu c'est des gens qui vont être faciles
à former s'il ya cette prise de
conscience et cette motivation justement
avoir un enfant dans sa globalité six
heures par jour
c'est sociale je suis super contente
part à mon profil convient vous voyez
enseigné dès septembre complètement ah
oui j'attends que ça j'ai fait des
stages là pendant l'année 2021 2022 ça a
confirmé en fait que je voulais faire ça
dans quinze jours les candidats sauront
s'ils ont été sélectionnés après un
second entretien
ils seront formés cet été avant
d'enseigner dès septembre
laurence à manosque et qu'est ce que
vous pensez de cette opération de job
dating ça rassure ou pas les parents de
voir que finalement il ya quand même
beaucoup de candidats ou au contraire
vous trouvé la méthode un peu
particulière alors c'est la forme qui
changent puisque le recours aux
contractuels de manière très massif
existe depuis maintenant très longtemps
je crois je me souviens aussi j'avais
discuté avec l'ancien directeur
académique des hauts-de-seine qui
m'avait dit que en 2016 il pour 1800
places à pourvoir il n'y avait eu que
900 candidats pour l'examen n'ont pas de
reçu donc vous imaginez donc depuis
combien de temps la situation s'installe
sauf que là ya urgence ainsi non mais
l'urgence elle est pas nous voyons donc
quelque part d'un côté bien sûr on
aimerait plutôt d'avoir des enseignants
qu'ils soient dûment formés
malheureusement il ya effectivement
cette urgence que l'académie propos ce
système de job dating si ça permet de
trouver des talents est d'amener vers
quelque chose façon on fait déjà un
recours aux contractuels donc on n'a pas
les enseignants donc voyons ce que ça va
donner mais espérons aussi que cet été
sera vraiment mis à profit pour leur
formation et qui se retrouvent pas
projeté du jour au lendemain devant les
élèves après il faut pas non plus si
j'ai les contractuels on a eu des des
contractuels qui se sont avérées avoir
une vraie fibre d'enseignement des gens
qui ont été formidables les parents on a
des fois même manifesté pour pouvoir les
garder parce qu'on voulait nous les
enlever pour les matériels pas trop en
faveur des concours
tout est possible je vous entends
finalement non attention
la formation la pédagogie on ne prend
pas du tout
la légère bien au contraire mais
effectivement
mais il faut absolument recruter et
motiver les enseignants peut-être aussi
quelque part que s'il ya une implication
un peu plus du directeur d'école pour le
climat scolaire on voit que dans les
écoles où il ya un bonne entente entre
les parents d'élèves entre le directeur
d'école entre les équipes pédagogiques
et que ça fonctionne bien l'attractivité
de l'école elle change complètement moi
j'ai dans une école qui avait du mal à
recruter et qui a complètement basculé
et aujourd'hui ils savent plus quoi
faire des élèves
de quel profit le profond manque le plus
les mathématiques notamment tous des
mathématiques des professeurs d'anglais
des professeurs de technologie des
professeurs de lettres on manque de tout
aujourd'hui on manque de tout les speed
dating ça me fait bien rire est ce que
vous irez chez un médecin qui a été
recruté sur un coin de table en 30
minutes est ce que vous montrez dans un
avion d'un pilote qui a été recruté
comme ça sur vous fait pas confiance à
l'académie de versailles pour repérer
des profils qui soit
suffisamment compétents c'est la touche
ça fait des années que ça dure pourquoi
est-ce qu'on se pose la mauvaise
question au lieu de sévir ailleurs au
moins c'est honnête oui mais l'accession
pourquoi pourquoi on en arrive là en
fait aujourd'hui fait comme on dit que
le climat scolaire s'est amélioré la
seule façon d'améliorer le climat
scolaire et pas ici j'ai dit que le
climat scolaire est un facteur d'être
active mais fondamentale et comment la
meilleure le plan scolaire que j'ignore
en augmentant les salaires mayor en
augmentant en améliorant les conditions
de travail c'est à dire - élèves d'un
classe parce qu'aujourd'hui dans la
plupart des collèges on a traîné elles
sont à 30 par classe l'année plupart des
lycées ses 35 il ya plus d'un e s h
parce que on les paie une misère et que
c'est scandaleux de faire ça il ya plus
de usa jeu pour s'occuper des élèves en
situation de handicap les classes sont
de plus en plus en plus hétérogènes dont
vous avez vous vu les conditions
de ce métier là d'enseignants se
dégrader sur quoi les cinq les dix
dernières années très concrètement bien
sûr mais bien sûr qu'il ait pas trop tôt
oui c'est quoi c'est un coup de
communication alors c'est d'assumer une
pratique qui est qui existe depuis
longtemps et qui se faisait un petit peu
en douce il ya quelques années il y
avait eu un reportage sur envoyé spécial
jeux je crois ou montrait déjà déjà cela
juste une remarque moi ça fait 40 ans
que j'enseigne j'ai le souvenir de
collet qui avait commencé comme ce qu'on
appelait à l'époque que emma maître
auxiliaire et qui étaient d'excellents
professeurs smith pour autant ce que je
dis et là je parle aussi avec ma
casquette de professeur formateur à
l'insp et l'institut national supérieur
du professeur et de l'éducation c'est
que la formation initiale elle est quand
même fondamental à la fois sur le plan
académique on recrute quand même
aujourd'hui à bac + 5 alors je sais pas
si c'est forcément une bonne idée de
d'avoir avancé avancé le concours à bac
plus cinq mais on n'a pas le temps
d'entamer ce débat c'est sûr là
l'enseignement le fait même dorée
alors tout à l'heure on disait oui ils
sont motivés je peux vous dire que les
étudiants que j'avais tout à l'heure
encore
en course cet après midi pour passer les
concours ils sont eux aussi ultra
motivés et que par ailleurs ils vivent
des situations extrêmement difficiles
puisqu'ils doivent préparer en même
temps un master un concours que ils sont
responsables qui sont défavorisés
aujourd'hui par rapport à des
contractuels ils reçoivent ces
reportages là comme une sorte de gifles
1 je le dis en reprenant en mettant dans
ma bouche les mots de mes étudiants de
cet a priori qu'est ce que vous proposez
vous phase aller à l'ignorer de
recrutement d'enseignants classics qui
refusons refaisons le film effectivement
là depuis quelques années on fait le
gros dos d'une certaine manière en
attendant que passe le le boom
démographique des années des années 2000
on a effectivement pas suffisamment
recruter et c'est vrai qu'en plus le
décalage ne concourt à créer de fait un
creux de vague ça pour une fois je vais
dire que monsieur blanc caire avait
raison sur cet aspect mais pas ailleurs
ne répétez pas cette cascade mais
surtout voilà l'erreur non mais pour
redevenir sérieux ce qui est
faux pour redevenir attractif je
reprends aussi les mots de mon collègue
par rapport aux salaires pour moi c'est
une revalorisation inconditionnel qu'il
faut et puis c'est aussi en effet
redonné du du pouvoir d'agir aux
enseignants et on revient sur notre 1er
mai mais on revient on revient alors
juste un dernier mot on revient on
revient au cinéma revient aussi sur cinq
ans de l'enquêté marquée par un mépris
technocratique une verticalité en
utilisait tout à l'heure les termes de
top down enfin de bottom up blanc caire
c'est un peu tôt
et l'homme de la situation on sent que
voilà le corps enseignant est en crise
après les années blanc caire qui ont
complètement et ça il faut le
reconnaître orthez les syndicats le
corps enseignant est ce que vous pensez
que il trouvera la méthode les mots et
l'action
je suis persuadé qu'il continuera à
faire vivre la promesse républicaine
comme on essaye de le faire depuis
longtemps ce que je voudrais simplement
bien je veux bien que tout soit la faute
de jean michel blanquer de d'emmanuel
macron mais ce qui est intéressant de
voir c'est que le manque d'appétence
pour les métiers de l'enseignant et les
problèmes de recrutement pour les
métiers de l'enseignement c'est le cas
dans tous les pays d'europe et c'est le
cas y compris aux etats-unis
c'est-à-dire qu'on se rend compte que ce
métier n'attire plus et donc on peut
effectivement incriminé untel ou untel
mais je pense que collectivement ça nous
interpelle et que c'est vraiment un
sujet de société qui mérite qu'on s'y
attarde place pour exactement ça craint
les comprimés
va garder des consultations avec les
syndicats avant les contours d'un d'un
futur projet doit on en est qu'au début
on l'a bien compris merci beaucoup merci
d'être venu sur le plateau de lcp pour
essayer quand même de commencer à
déchiffrer décrypter les projets
présidentiels en matière d'éducation va
à présent accueillir notre grand témoin
il a rencontré plusieurs fois la reine
elizabeth ii et plusieurs membres de la
famille royale il connaît mieux que
personne la saga des windsor il n'a
évidemment rien rater de la première
journée de cérémonies du jubilé de
platine 70 ans de règne un record on a
plein de questions à poser à marc roche
sur cette monarchie britannique qui nous
fascine tant comme les skis ce sujet
signée mario baker
si on vous invite marc roche c'est parce
que vous êtes le journaliste français
qui connaît sans doute le mieux la reine
d'angleterre
elizabeth ii qui célèbre depuis ce matin
ses 70 ans de règne un jubilé de platine
jamais aucun souverain britannique n'a
régné aussi longtemps si vous connaissez
aussi bien la monarchie marc roche c'est
que vous vivez depuis 30 ans à londres
d'abord correspondant pour le journal le
monde en tant que journaliste financier
fin connaisseur de la city vous
découvrez et vous vous délectez peu à
peu et des dessous de la monarchie à
laquelle vous consacré de nombreux
ouvrages dont le dernier les borgia à
buckingham dans cette fresque familiale
vous fait dialoguer la famille royale à
partir de faits réels vous reconstituer
des conversations entre will i am et
charme je refuse de mentir tu n'as pas
été un bon père tu as été totalement
absent de notre existence et camille art
qui déclare ce sont des malades anne est
une garce cynique anju un imbécile qui
ferait avec des pédophiles edouard une
chiffe molle
adultère débauche mute fratricide c'est
un portrait de famille terrible que vous
dressez celui aussi d'une reine
machiavélique et impitoyable qui a
façonné son petit fils william pour lui
succéder en supplantant le prince
charles tous les ingrédients sulfureux
digne de la légende des borgia cette
mythique famille alasuak de pouvoir qui
a défrayé la chronique dans l'italie de
la renaissance et pourtant les
britanniques ont préparé ce jubilé avec
ferveur la monarchie est plus populaire
que jamais et reste le ciment de la
nation jubilé de la reine elizabeth 2
marquant le 70e anniversaire de son
accession au trône est très important
dès le premier jubilé où il ya un
recentrage de la famille royale sur le
noyau dur à savoir
m le prince charles le prince william et
le prince george et tous les autres
membres de la famille royale ont été
marginalisés par rapport à cette
opération destinée à améliorer le
rapport qualité prix de la monarchie est
désormais correspondant pour le point
chroniqueur pour le journal le soir et
la bbc consultant pour tf1 et lci vous
avez observé de près les premières
festivités de ce jubilé ce salut au
balcon si lourd de sens alors marc roche
on vous pose la question que dit cette
image au balcon avec les présents et
sans les bannis de l'état de la famille
royale
bonsoir marc roche dont son merci
infiniment de nous avoir accordé un peu
de temps dans cette journée vous étiez
absolument partout quelle journée de
jubilé de platine quatre jours quatre
jours fériés pour les britanniques à
pays tout entier qui s'arrête on va
répondre à cette question qui vous est
adressée par marion becker dans ce sujet
tout de suite les 18 membres qui étaient
sur le balcon du palais de buckingham à
la mi journée ont été triés sur le volet
on va regarder ensemble cette image
qu'est ce qu'elle dit de l'état de la
famille royale des présents et des
absents alors ce qu'il faut d'abord
savoir c'est que le balcon de buckingham
palace et l'interface entre la royauté
le peuple c'est là que les windsor se
donne en représentation et c'est aussi
le thermomètre de ou plutôt le baromètre
pardon de des relations entre les
membres du clan alors qu'est ce qu'on a
vu on a vu d'abord que ce la reine
elizabeth ii qui mène le bal le balcon
lui appartient elle est la locataire de
buckingham palace celle qui attribue
toutes les places et qui décide qui est
in et qui est rien n'est laissé au
hasard dans cette image dans chez les
windsor rien n'est laissé au hasard des
la manière dont ils se saby la manière
dont elle salue rien laisser au hasard
dont premier rang le plus important le
noyau dur la reine au centre flanqué
prince charles
ils sont héritiers prince william
deuxième dans l'ordre de succession
leurs épouses et les trois enfants du
prince william derrière ce qu'on appelle
les working royal et membre actif de la
famille royale qui représente la reine
et qui son pays par l d'ailleurs pour
leur activité tout le reste les rebelles
ceux qui sont sortis des clous ont été
éliminés parce que la reine
a toujours fait passer les
considérations régaliennes avant les
comédies temps familial 6 par personne
megan et arrêts ne sont pas mes gars
nehari n'y sont pas puisque ils mènent
ils ont quitté la famille royale et en
plus il ya cette fameuse interview qui
sont donnés à oprah winfrey que la reine
a peu apprécié et ensuite un drogué un
draw évidemment être la boue c'est par
le scandale oui pour deux raisons
d'abord éclaboussé par le scandale et
chan qui en a fait un paria puisque la
reine qu'à régler de sa poche les 12 à
15 millions d'euros de l'accord à la map
assez avec l'accusatrice pour enterrer
la sphère donc cette image c'est
évidemment la reine elizabeth 2 96 ans
qu'il a décidé au millimètre comment
vous l'avez trouvé cette cérémonie vous
l'avez suivi minute par minute qu'est ce
qui restera qu'est ce qui vous a marqué
la royal air force qui fait ce chiffre
des 70 ans pour célébrer l'anniversaire
la parade militaire quelle image vous
garderez moi je regarderai l'image
d'abord du balcon mais de rennes est
extraordinaire d'abord d'un chic absolu
la branche était merveilleuse les
couleurs étaient celles du platine 1 et
elle est apparue en bonne santé ou du
moins avoir moins de problèmes de
mobilité la deuxième image qui m'a
fortement frappé vivant à londres depuis
1985 c'est la ferveur populaire
incroyable la liesse incroyable il n'y a
que la royauté qui peut créer une telle
ferveur non seulement auprès des
londoniens mais également des nombreux
touristes aient compris les touristes de
comme un noël donc les anciennes
colonies et les ex dominion et ses deux
choses la reine et le fait qu'elle a
rassuré sur son état de santé et
l'extraordinaire soutien populaire
montre que la royauté plus forte que
j'avais forte que jamais aujourd'hui où
elisabeth deux plus fortes que jamais
c'est pas la même chose parce que là
aussi on est à un tournant les
britanniques n'ont connu qu elle
aujourd'hui 96 ans sa santé décline
il leur disait aussi un peu revoir
aujourd'hui je dirais même plus que
c'est un adieu mahdi aura pas de nouveau
jubilé laisse faire sa mère a vécu
jusqu'à 100 et 2 ans je crois pas
qu'elle va vivre jusqu'à 100 ans et 6
ans sont cycliques rappaz sont grandes
elle n'abdiquera certainement puisque à
la mort elle regarde son serment et
religieux et c'est une femme très
croyante de servir son peuple jusqu'à sa
mort je la soupçonne également de
vouloir écourter le règne de son fils
qu'elle trouve trop progressiste trop
interventionniste trop dépensiers les
pingres la reine elizabeth ii et donc ça
va voir nous l'expliquions dans votre
livre elle favorise williams à la fin
mai à lima la monarchie qu'elle souhaite
à savoir conventionnelle conservatrice
non interventionniste traditionnelle y
est rare chic et finalement blanche
anglo saxon et protège les coûts de ces
adjectifs conventionnelle conservatrice
hiérarchique on a du mal à comprendre
pourquoi elle est si populaire parce que
c'est pas forcément des mots très
populaire ce que vous décrivez là 90%
d'opinions favorables comment vous
expliquez ça c'est d'autant plus
surprenant ce chiffre que
l'angleterre est une société
multiculturelle
multitechnique méritocratique qui ne
correspond pas du tout ni au protocole
ni ou pas les news gardes royaux ni aux
carrosses ni au glamour mais les
britanniques qui
ont toujours des leaders politiques
clivant reconnaissent dans l'arène un
facteur d'unité d'autant plus important
facteur d'unité qu'il y a des forces
centrifuges en écosse en irlande du nord
et dans le commonwealth dérives des
ppi dont elle est le chef de l'état qui
veulent devenir des république tout en
restant dans le commonwealth mais je
crois que c'est assez l'unité et les
sens du devoir le sens du devoir elle a
tout sacrifié aux deux voies et enfin
l'histoire cette extraordinaire histoire
elle est née en
1926 elle est liée au tsar et au kaiser
elle représente toute l'histoire de son
royaume avec grandeur et décadence
quand on voit les britanniques qui ont
comme traversé de très grosse crise a
divisé fracturé par le bras exit la
pandémie ça a été très très dur ou au
royaume uni compte revoir pendant quatre
jours fériés ils sont soudés derrière
leur raid mais aussi entre eux les les
familles les voisinages les amis se
retrouvent on se dit au fond la
monarchie ça a du bon on peut être un
peu jaloux un peu envieux des
britanniques le sacré ce qui crée du
lien niveau qu'il soit du côté d'un
monarque sans pouvoir plutôt qu'un
monarque républicain comme en france
absolument le sacré qui lie les
britanniques bien que ce ne soit plus du
tout comme par le passé une société
protestante puisqu'elle est une mini
qu'aujourd'hui il ya plus de pratiquants
musulmans ou catholiques que d'anglicans
dans les églises le dimanche mais vous
savez c'est un point fixe dans la
tourmente vous avez mentionné le bric
side qui a divisé le pays comme jamais
pendant plus de quatre ans la pandémie
qui a été très mortels au royaume uni à
toutes les erreurs du gouvernement
johnson et puis la reine dans les deux
cas à réconforter le pays elle n'est
jamais intervenu au niveau politique
jamais et vous serez on va voir ce
chapeau qu'on a beaucoup commenté ce
chapeau bleu orné de petites fleurs
jaunes
dont beaucoup ont vu le signe du drapeau
européen vous vous dites le contraire
vous êtes persuadé que la reine était
propres exit jeune fille elle ne pouvait
absolument rien dit elle n'a jamais rien
dit mais je suis persuadé qu'elles
étaient propres et que c'est à cause de
son éducation au sommaire à cause de son
amour de la campagne à cause de son
loyauté au commonwealth qui a quand même
perdu de vitesse à cause de l'union
européenne et parce qu'elle représente
l'angleterre profonde l'angleterre
patriotes l'angleterre nationaliste donc
elle a un profil de break sitter est
donc ce chapeau pour moi est une
opération visant à montrer qu'elle n'est
pas breakes sitter ans je dirais c'est
1-1 dans un match de foot bal au 100 m
dos à elle est neutre elle et l'arbitré
alors on parle on a tout petit peu de ce
livre qui se dévore parce que évidemment
ce qui est fascinant c'est que tout est
fondé sur des faits véridiques mais vous
faites des scènes et des dialogues entre
tous les membres de la famille royale je
rappelle que vous avez déjà rencontré la
reine elizabeth ii et plusieurs membres
de la famille roy des royals comparer
les windsor aux borgia franchement bon
le poison et le sang en moins quand même
si vous y allez fort vous dites ya tous
les ingrédients
l'adultère la débauche le sexe des
luttes pour le pouvoir comment il est né
ce projet là les borgia buckingham le
projet est né lors des funérailles du
duc d'edimbourg l'époux de la reine
pendant
73 gens quand on a vu cette image de
tous les membres mâles de la famille
royale défilé derrière le catafalque
et je me suis dit mais quel mensonge
ils ont l'air tous d'être unis alors
qu'ils se détestent qu'ils se battent
pour avoir les meilleures
représentations qui se battent pour
l'argent de la reine et je me suis dit
ah mais c'est les borgia est alors bien
sûr chaque dès que j'ai dix agents
durant exagérons il veut faire vendre sa
camelote mais l'on sait les borgia parce
que c'est une famille
en apparence unis mais qui est
profondément profondément
dysfonctionnelle comme toutes les
familles arrivent vous pourriez dire que
toutes les familles dysfonctionnelles je
retiendrai cet adjectif merci infiniment
marc roche les borgia à buckingham
indiscrétions et scandales comme si vous
y étiez autant dire qu'on se régale
c'est aux éditions albin michel vous
propose de de rester avec moi c'est
l'heure d'accueillir nos a franchi pour
leur parti-pris vous êtes vous faire
réagir ce soir évidemment d'un gamin et
son carnet de campagne des législatives
zoom sur la droite quelles sont ses
chances de victoire dans cette élection
la sémiologue mariette darrigrand qui va
explorer pour nous un mot dans l'acte eu
cette semaine des et bien sûr à
moins de deux semaines du scrutin et
puis emmanuel ducrocq de l'opinion
manifestement agacé par une tribune dans
le monde qui prônerait le retour à la
terre explications avec noah frottis
tout de suite au féminin pluriel bonsoir
mesdames on sera ravi de vous retrouvez
alors on commence avec le carnet de
campagne d'hazare ce soit vous
intéressez à la droite c'est vrai qu'on
parle très peu un des républicains dans
cette campagne oui pour vous dire j'ai
croisé une député de droite sortante ce
matin je lui ai dit que j'allais
consacrer ma chronique à son camp alors
venez pas elle me dit pourtant plus
personne ne parle de nous c'est vrai
qu'on s'interroge pour savoir si la
majorité aura une majorité confortable
on se demande si jean luc mélenchon et
la nuque devons réussir son pari on
s'interroge sur la compagne un petit peu
sous les radars du rassemblement
national mais on parle de nous un de la
droite après le score on rappelle moins
de 5% de valérie pécresse au premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle
pourtant ici à l'assemblée nationale
c'était bien le premier groupe
d'opposition 100 députés sortants et
c'est vrai que dans les sondages mais
leur donne deux fois moins autour de 50
au mieux alors sur le terrain comment ça
se passe pour les républicains dans quel
état d'esprit sont ils alors déjà ils
ont été soulagés soulagé parce qu'après
la présidentielle on prédisait un exode
de députés vers la majorité
ça n'a pas été le cas finalement il y en
a cinq seulement qu'on franchit le
rubicon donc ça c'est un peu un motif de
satisfaction après il a fallu digérer
aussi le départ du président du groupe
damien abad au gouvernement mais il
semblerait que ça a pu resserrer un peu
les troupes quand le chef par les
troupes se resserre mais une député et
puis alors ils sont évidemment aux
compagnies une campagne extra locale une
campagne de terrain une campagne à
l'ancienne il faut voir tout le monde
serrer des mains faire des bises aller
dans chaque ville chaque village de sa
circonscription il mise sur l'ancrage
local et il met en avant il ya un
argument e serons une opposition
responsable
écoutez gérard larcher c'est le
président du sénat il était en campagne
pour un député nous avons besoin de
cette opposition républicaine forte
indépendante il ya une sacrée
responsabilité imaginer que l'opposition
ne soit un corner que par la france
soumise ou par le rassemblement national
ce qui ne manquera pas quelque chose de
très profonde démocratie voilà et gérard
larcher était venu ce jour là soutenir
aurélien pradié quai numéro trois des
républicains et qui n'a pas de candidat
de la majorité face à lui oui c'est un
peu étonnant et c'est pas du tout parce
qu aurélien pas le prénom il est ma
critique incompatibles il est très
critique il n'a pas s est pas du tout
pour le remercier de position d'avoir sa
prise de position pour l'entre-deux
tournant c'est parce que dans cette
circonscription il ya un candidat
socialiste dissident donc qui n'est donc
pas le candidat de la nuque c'est rémi
branco il a ses chances et la majorité
bien n'a pas souhaité rajouter un
candidat alors qu'il ya aussi un risque
rassemblement national dans cette
circonscription la vie politique
française intéresse la reine je crois à
l adore la france s quel profil
ecoutez-le antoine est francophile
francophone et la seule fois moi je vais
rencontrer souvent elle m'a toujours
posé des trois mêmes questions depuis
combien d'années êtes vous là monsieur
rousies plaisait est ce que le temps la
météo ne vous ennuie pas trop et la
seule fois où j'ai réussi à lui soutirer
quelque chose de substantiel c'était en
2002 lors de l'élection présidentielle
française quand je lui ai dit vous savez
votre majesté ce pas brillé en france
elle me dit j'espère que les français
voteront bien le lendemain mon journal
donc le monde a titré
rhin de vote pour jacques chirac
c'est pour l'anecdote on l'avait oublié
mariette mariette ce soir on s'intéresse
à un mot le mot de député je rappelle
que vous êtes sémiologue alors on
s'intéresse au fond pourquoi on dit pas
élection d putative pourra le dire
pourquoi législatives oui on pourrait
tout à fait de lire parce que le député
n'est pas le seul à écrire et à voter
pour la loi il y en ad'autres alors
c'est comme si ce mot de députés
n'étaient pas assez noble en fait le
député il est un petit peu pris en
sandwich entre le maire qui est toujours
bien aimé ou bien critiquer mais qui
proches et le président de la république
mais la fonction suprême il est admiré
outre jugé trop arrogant mais enfin il
est loin et lui le député il est un peu
entre entre les deux et du coup ce je
pense qu'il n'est pas aidé par son nom
parce que qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
députés on sait plus députés ça veut
dire simplement déléguer comme délégué
du personnel délégués de classe même
donc le mot ne porte pas la noblesse du
rapport à la loi alors ça veut dire que
si on s'en tient avec synology député
c'est un verbe c'est ça au départ de gap
qu'on a complètement perdu on ne dit
plus je débute eu des buts et c'est pas
très joli mais c'était un ferme qui
avait beaucoup d'intérêt parce que il il
disait ben on envoie quelqu'un d'abord
un il disait dons on envoie quelqu'un
sur le terrain c'est un peu un émissaire
on en voit on en voit avec une certaine
autorité donc c'est plus du tout c'était
pas du tout le rapport qu'on a
aujourd'hui avec nos députés qui nous
supplient d'être scellé voilà c'est ça
c'était un rapport plus autoritaire où
c'étaient eux qui étaient envoyés mais à
l'origine safe si on remonte le temps il
ya 2 il ya deux couches en quelque sorte
un il ya une première couche du du
député qui est tout simplement celui qui
va parler à notre place donc c'est le
représentant et là c'est pas forcément
politique pas forcément de citoyens
voilà présentant ça peut être deux un
groupe de personnes voilà donc par
exemple chez flaubert au 19ème on a
encore une expression génial ammann
évite les députés des betteraves ouais
il s'amusait avec se parler du monde
paysan qui était pas encore politique
pour avoir la dimension politique faut
s'inscrire évidemment dans l'esprit des
lois montesquieu et c'est là et c est là
on retrouve évidemment cette importance
de la démocratie ou la loi nous
obéissons à des lois votées et non pas
des lois imposées par un roi ou par un
despote et on voit bien actuellement que
ça peux tu revenir cette chose là quelle
est l'origine mais le récit s'avère
débuté alors génial quand on est proche
du latin fait députés ça voulait dire
nettoyer faire le propre donc par
exemple députés des arbres c'étaient les
élaguer donc il ya une dimension de
propreté qui est assez ironique assez
intéressante de pureté aussi peut-être
est-ce que vous voulez nous renvoyer aux
futurs députés qui ont un devoir
d'exemplarité c'est ça que vous pointez
absolue une forme de message mais ça je
l'aï lord leurs fonctions réalité bien
sûr à avoir avec la loi mais à avoir
avec ce oui effectivement l'exemplarité
une sorte de pureté de ceux de ce
travail de représentation
députés
ump comment on dire en anglais m mais
ils sont beaucoup plus en contact avec
leurs constituants qu'en france
parce que il doit avaler toutes les
semaines dans leur circonscription et
reçoivent même si son premier ministre
une dizaine de
deux membres de leur
constitue une scie et puis surtout c'est
un régime parlementaire c'est un vrai
rien à voir beaucoup plus qu'en france
emmanuel on termine avec vous vous aviez
envie de nous parler ce soir d'un maire
qui courent quand on parle d'agriculture
après les diplômés d'agroparistech qui
veulent démissionner c'est une tribu
dans le mode qui vous a mis la puce à
l'oreille une tribune qui incite à
reprendre la terre aux machines en
installant des millions de paysans oui
c'est un air connu qui a déjà été
entamée récemment par le site reporter
l'auteur de la tribune qui est paru hier
dans le monde et viticulteurs et il
explique que la seule façon sortir des
pesticides c'est de réinstaller un
million de paysans et de reprendre donc
la terre aux machines et bien évidemment
de changer de modèle et pour vous c'est
pas du tout un changement modèle c'est
le contraire une agriculture qui repose
sur la force de travail sans intrants et
sans mécanisation on sait exactement ce
que c'est c'est la france de 1935 une
france qui comptait 41 millions
d'habitants environ 30% de paysans
aujourd'hui c'est 1,1 1,2 pour cent de
la population et nous sommes 70 millions
alors c'était une agriculture qui avait
plein de petits bras vaillant les
enfants parce que je vous rappelle que
les vacances d'été sont les vacances des
moissons c'était une agriculture où les
rendements étaient quatre fois
inférieurs où l'espérance de vie d'un
homme à la naissance était de 55 ans
aujourd'hui ses 78 ans et demi c'était
une agriculture de misère de souffrance
qui s'incarne dans une maladie
l'applicateur champêtre cette maladie du
dos cassé qu'on attrapait aristée
courbet au ras du sol et pourquoi cette
fascination selon vous de l'idée de
reprendre la terre aux machines d'où ça
vient eh bien je ne sais pas je ne sais
pas autant une agriculture des sorties
des pesticides c'est le sens de
l'histoire ça finira par arriver mais si
on se borne à dire il faut sortir des
pesticides c'est entre 30 et 50% des
volumes en moins qu'on produira alors
qu'ils ne mangera pas si tu quand même
une vraie question il faut des solutions
techniques mécaniques pour désherber par
exemple des solutions agronomiques de la
génétique des plantes pour avoir des
plantes qu'ils soient résistantes aux
maladies qu'on n'ait pas besoin de
traiter parce que le rêve
rêve d'un million d'agriculteurs
supplémentaires alors qu'on arrive même
pas à recruter 450 milles saisonniers
agricoles pour moi c'est une illusion
une illusion coûte cette agriculture là
ne produira que de la nourriture très
cher que seuls les plus riches pourront
se se payer et puis la sortie des
machines c'est le refus de la science le
refus l'innovation c'est espérer que les
mêmes causes produiront des effets
différents qu'en 1935 à vrai dire c'est
totalement romantique 1c judéo chrétien
c'est un peu écolo doloriste il faut
souffrir pour se nourrir il faut un peu
s'excuser d'exister enfin il faut
surtout que d'autres souffrent parce que
ceux qui défendent cette agriculture le
plus souvent n'ont pas la moindre idée
de ce qu'elle était et surtout ils n'ont
pas la moindre envie de prendre la
binette à leur tour merci voilà parti
pris ça existe aussi ce débat au royaume
uni bien sûr mais vous savez le prince
charles est intervenu sur l'agriculture
sur les ogm et c'est un débat on a
exactement le même débat avec les mêmes
choses ce qui est bien c'est que la
reine en fait tu manges peut elle
chipote et elle mange peu et id est elle
même est très écolo dans l'exploitation
de 2,7 mais de là à fait paraît
totalement l'homme de la machine et de
reprendre au fond les la terre les
paysans sans machine je ne suis pas sûr
enfin elle ne pourrait pas le dire de
toute façon elle n'a pas eu la
possibilité
merci infiniment marc roche les borgia à
buckingham c'est chez albin michel merci
à vous les affranchis tout de suite
votre soirée documentaire merci d'avoir
suivi cette émission bien sûr un film de
anne gauthier sur le handicap le rêve
américain de valentin très belle soirée
et demain
[Musique]